Celine Dion dropped three new songs from
her new album including the title track
courage here is a bit of that what do
you think so courage don't you dare
filming
cuz it's easy when you're not with me
this well
goes first
Wow you keep going so Cheryl sat down
with Celine a few weeks ago to talk
about what courage means to her at this
point of her life and career talk about
courage the album what that's why again
that's why it's this whole thing right
now about the read about the fierce
about the strength about the courage of
saying no about the courage about yes
the courage about saying this is what I
want to do courage about saying that I
want to be involved and I that's what I
want to do this is my team this these
are the people that I want to work with
making choices I want to be involved I
love to wear that I can't please
everyone they didn't like it well I'm
sorry tomorrow you might like what I
will wear so why do you not you have the
courage to be that now because I'm 51
years old because I'm a mother because
ronnie has given me so much strength
through the years because when he left
to his other life he had given me the
rest of the luggage I became you know
yeah
solo mom yeah I became in charge of that
okay if I don't take charge of my dreams
of my team of showing even just to
myself that I can do this and I really
want to then what am i what am I gonna
do why why would I keep good I don't
need to keep going
mr. just have to do record any music no
I want to and yes that song it's exactly
what we want to hear from Celine your
classic ballad anyway I like about it
too is that she really doesn't go for
the big notes in it there's still some
big vocals in it but you know slim
usually goes to a street usually it's
interesting because I'd only notice that
when you mention that just now that she
doesn't go for the big notes but to me
Selena's entire voice is big know she
sings one note right yeah like
everything is large but I know I know
what you're saying I started getting
nervous when there was all these stories
that she may be collaborating with all
these different people and I thought
that we were gonna get a completely
different remember the flying on my own
yeah this is a dance song yes yeah but
this is what I was this is sort of what
I was hoping for it's a beautiful song
and she's the best that carmine says
love the song our just says Wow three
new songs from Slean yeah she's going in
the direction of music now to introduce
releasing a bunch of songs do it I know
it says it's very much Celine as we six
expect but I like it she's wonderful and
funny she can sing hymn cited for the
new album Timothy says the song is
amazing and it's funny - one of the
other songs I think it's called lying
down it's written by David Guetta and
SIA but it's not a dance song no I think
there's a little bit of a beat to it
yeah so is it because I was expecting
what's gonna explode into one of these
dance songs but it doesn't so yeah she's
very much sticking with the style that
people love her but maybe going a little
bit inside the agency is really great
with that because she has worked with
some people that you wouldn't expect her
to normally work with but but her
extreme talent is SIA can write for
other people's voice to the point of
where it just sounds like you've heard
that song forever like Celine songs like
that song I just heard for the first
time now but I'm like feels like I've
been in my life forever
like it's just Celine like that's all
that's all it is yeah Kenny says a lot
of the three new songs they sound great
and so fresh I hope you hear
imperfections that's the other one or
lying down on the radio so yeah we'll
see what song she actually goes with
you're a single but yeah good stuff